let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
good afternoon everybody welcome to
episode
five of let's talk the tony michaels
podcast
there's a few things going on in the
world today if you haven't been paying
attention
just a couple maybe something
significant
maybe a trial of someone significant
well he used to be significant
mr donald j trump
the former ex-slob president
is on trial today if you haven't heard
if you haven't been watching
and i'm sure we'll get to that today we
will talk about
the trial today but first things first
we have to get a few things out of a way
there's a little bit of business to get
to here
we have uh someone with us today as we
normally do
sammy's here with us today but i have to
ask her a few
non-super bowl questions here
um it is very important that i ask her
if you
non super bowl questions we're going to
talk so
we're going to talk about the super bowl
get out of here
let's so let's let's uh let's try to
dance around this
uh issue of what happened on sunday
let's not talk about what happened on
sunday
because we don't want to upset any of
the
the people whose team might not have the
one um
we don't want to upset those people you
know anyone that would be humongous fans
of that
team that lost it
so but i see i see you have your royal
shirt on again so obviously you're
looking forward
you're looking forward to a different
kansas city team is that uh
is that what's happening let's just
let's bring baseball back
and let's let's let's put the past in
the past
in the past you know the you know the
good news is that uh
they didn't lose by like you know just
barely
so that's the good news that's the good
news it wasn't like a like a barn burner
you you you had this slow walk in the
second half of
this this guy is not a god he is a human
being
uh patrick mahomes is is uh
he is a human being so we did we did
prove that on
on sunday so yep but you know there's
always next year
can you imagine if they go to the super
bowl three years in a row oh they'll
they'll go
we'll make sure how sweet would that be
it'd be pretty sweet
pretty sweet yeah you know again there's
always baseball right
always baseball so have you have you
been paying attention today to
the great trial of the x
uh disgrace president donald trump not a
clue
fill me in anything okay so so i have to
i have to give you a little
insight today on the podcast while
you're listening and uh we'll forget
about
last sunday and we'll move on to maybe
next sunday maybe something will
will happen good okay next sunday when
does baseball season start what what's
that what's the starting day
that the catchers report is in a week
right
the first royals game what's they
haven't scheduled yet there's not a
schedule yet
okay so i'm hoping soon
yeah across well maybe maybe we get
maybe
by the time we get to summer and fall
there'll be uh uh we'll be in there
covet
cove covet will be better people be more
people be able to go to the ball games
which
i think that'll be a good thing for our
country to get back to more normal
you know doing [ __ ] that we used to do
i hope so i think thanks for joining us
today sammy and um
my condolences to you and your husband
steve
thank you on sunday yeah all right dude
we'll talk to you soon
all right so let's get into the trial
have you guys been watching this [ __ ]
it is absolutely crazy over there
in the senate so yesterday
was a complete utter liquid [ __ ] show
especially on donald trump's side uh
they had to
they had to pretend that they were going
to ask the question
rather the trial was going to be
constitutional or not
rather you could try someone
because they quit their job or not
this is all [ __ ] ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous that you can't try
someone that you've indicted
even after they decided to quit their
job or they got fired from their job
what of course you can he was impeached
while he was president
and i'll get into this a little bit
today but every single one of the
the house members that are the democrats
that are trying this case
in the senate referred to him today as
president trump
as if he was presently the president and
the reason why i think this is a damn
good argument to make even though it
makes me sick to hear them
say president trump and not former
president trump because he's really
former was once was will never be
president again trump but the reason why
they keep
saying president trump specifically is
to make the argument that this guy was
president when this [ __ ] happened
and this wasn't just one isolated
incident on january 6
where this bonehead got up in front of a
podium and riled up his crowd
this was a series of events and that's
what they laid out today but yesterday
they talked about the constitutionality
of this
of this trial and if you
watched yesterday the first half you
watched
uh uh representative jamie raskin
and uh uh i believe his name
is gnusk i believe
of colorado they made strong hard
arguments did a fantastic job
really laced this constitutionality uh
up
just right and laid out that [ __ ]
case beautifully
and then
oh and then we got donald trump's
[ __ ] legal teams
take on it holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] where did these [ __ ] get
their law degree
out of a [ __ ] crackerjack box or
something is this
are these internet lawyers what the
actual [ __ ] is going on
so the first the first lawyer bruce
castor you can't under you he got up
there and you couldn't understand a
[ __ ] thing he was saying he was
rambling on about state sen
about senators wooing them
trying to get his knee pads out to
impress the senators as if it has
anything to do with the senators at this
point
other than the legacy vote that they're
about to make
and it is a legacy vote here and i'll
explain that here in a little bit
but he he rambles on and on and on go
incoherently and apparently
uh that the the cheeto confederacy
president
mango jesus donald trump was [ __ ]
infuriated by his defense
and that is the first indication that
something is seriously [ __ ] wrong
when donald trump is pissed off about a
lawyer's defense of him
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that attorney has done
some wildly crazy [ __ ] i mean we watch
rudy giuliani and cindy powell and lynn
wood
and these boneheads try to make
arguments for this idiot for months and
months and months after the election
as if it was stolen
and he didn't say one word he oh they're
great they're fantastic
fantastic rudy's a great guy stand up
guy great guy
you did a good job
but when you're pissed off about the
arguments yesterday which honestly
if i was gonna get billed and not pay a
bill that would be
the one i mean donald trump is
definitely not gonna pay his bill for
these attorneys that's just donald trump
but if it were me and that was the
defense i probably would question
whether i would pay that bill because
that defense from bruce castor [ __ ]
sucked
it was incoherent you couldn't
understand a [ __ ] thing he was
talking about
and it had nothing to do with the case
he made no case whatsoever
and you had uh david scone i think is
how you say his last name
uh come up and give his case same
[ __ ]
same [ __ ] just a little louder just
a louder a little a little more angry
into the microphone
and the only really compelling case that
these two morons made in the two hours
that they talked
was on the word and where they were
talking about the part
convict and remove they focused on that
word that was the only
compelling argument that these two
knuckleheads these shitty morons [ __ ]
made in the entire two hours
the only one and it wasn't that [ __ ]
compelling
because they only spent about three
minutes on it
i mean if that's your best case you
spend two hours on the word and
surely surely these [ __ ] boneheads
gonna come up with some way to talk
about the word and
and convict and remove for two goddamn
hours
but they couldn't so they rambled on
about other [ __ ] that didn't have
anything to do with the
constitutionality of an impeachment nor
trial and in the end in the end
yesterday
we had six republicans six vote for the
constitutionality
which it's kind of disappointing that
there wasn't more
but if you think about it if you think
about this in the grand scheme of things
yesterday the two votes that were kind
of
uh out there that that weren't sure if
we what votes we were going to get
number one was bill cassidy
and his argument was after the fact his
argument for his vote
to say that this is constitutional is
that donald trump's lawyers are
[ __ ] dumbasses that's i mean not so
many words that's not a quote
that's what it meant they were [ __ ]
stupid
they made stupid [ __ ] arguments for a
stupid amount of time
and they didn't earn his vote even ted
cruz
said that the democrats did better than
trump's lawyers what
holy [ __ ] now ted cruz didn't vote uh
that it was constitutional but
he still said these people were [ __ ]
dumb and when ted cruz
when ted cruz says that your arguments
suck and you're
you're bad at your job holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you need to re
re-evaluate what the [ __ ] you're doing
maybe these guys need to go back
to school for something else other than
being a [ __ ] lawyer
and maybe we need to reevaluate how easy
it is to
[ __ ] take a bar exam in this country
if these two are lawyers jesus
and then we had pat toomey of
pennsylvania
uh vote for the constitutionality which
was kind not really a surprise
you knew he you knew he was on the list
of people that possibly would vote
for the constitutionality of this and
the reason why is because bruce castor
stood there and
basically uh gave pat toomey fellatio
into the microphone
rambled on and on and on about how he's
from pennsylvania and pacquiao is from
pennsylvania and they butt buddies and
all this [ __ ]
give him all kinds of [ __ ] and i
guess pat toomey
heard not a single [ __ ] word of that
[ __ ] or heard it and thought
yeah this is directly out of trump's
[ __ ] mouth
and then the other republicans that
voted against
ben sasse which is not really a surprise
here uh ben sasse's
over the last month has really made it
since january 6 really
and before that you know he's he's stuck
the knife in the donald trump a couple
times
um he's really trying to make sure that
everyone knows that he is anti-trump
uh in the republican party he doesn't
want trump in the party he doesn't want
trump ideas he doesn't want trumpism in
the party uh he thinks it's a cancer
uh the same thing that mitch mcconnell
thinks of marjory taylor green
so that was not a surprise that ben
sasse got his vote on the
constitutionality this and of course we
got mitt romney murkowski and collins
uh which those were pretty much in the
bank for this but it didn't matter
it didn't matter how many voted it
didn't matter because
because the democrats have 51 votes if
they need them
and that's the significance here of the
six votes
that republicans gave is they didn't
have to have the vote
so sixth republican thinks it's better
for them because
all all these republicans do is vote
based on what's good for them
not what's good for the country for
goddamn sure
so at least six republicans think that
it's a good idea to vote
for the constitutionality of this trial
and to try donald trump
now i don't know if we'll get all six of
these [ __ ] to convict him
but my guess is we're gonna get some to
join him here
because by the time we wrap up the 16
hours of of testimony
of of uh yeah testimony from the house
members
the house managers by the time we wrap
this 16 hours up
and then we get on to the the trump
lawyers of their rebuttal holy [ __ ]
that's gonna be a
a [ __ ] circus i'm gonna have content
for
[ __ ] months over that
by the time we get through this this
week
i wouldn't be surprised if there's eight
to ten republicans
that will vote to convict and the reason
why is because in the long term
of things it is going to make way more
sense politically for their political
capital and their political careers
to vote to convict this [ __ ] now
will they get 16
probably not probably not but there's
also there's also
this this uh you know suggestion that
maybe just maybe
maybe mitch mcconnell is whipping
republican votes in private in secret
he's whipping he's whipping for to
convict in private
and because there's there's 16 senators
republican senators that definitely want
to vote to convict if it was on a secret
ballot
they would vote to convict in a
heartbeat because here's the deal if
they vote to convict donald trump but
they really do convict him
which i don't think they will but if
there were 16 senators that went out on
a limb and wanted to do what they really
want to [ __ ] do here
which is get rid of this [ __ ]
convicting him even though they wouldn't
remove him from office anywhere
would bury him politically and would
basically make mitch mcconnell the
leader of the republican party
is what it would do and you would have
uh these
q anon maga knuckleheads like marjorie
taylor green
bobert trump mo brooks
uh holly they would splinter off
into their own party which is i think
what they're trying to avoid
they're trying to grasp power here and
hang on to the republican party where
whereas mitch mcconnell is is trying to
get them
out of the party because i think mitch
mcconnell is making the calculation that
even people who voted for donald trump
on
on november 3rd and still believe he is
somehow this was stolen from him
are always going to vote with the person
with the r next to their name that's the
bet he's making
here and if he can be the re the leader
of the republican party
then possibly they can salvage it
possibly
but we'll see we'll see
and the arguments today are are very
simple uh they they they're starting to
break down the video that they had
yesterday which the 10 minute video
should be required watching for every
single [ __ ] american
in this country the house managers
yesterday played at the very beginning
of their arguments a video
it's kind of like a documentary of
footage
cryologically from from january 6 laying
out
the siege on the capitol from start to
finish
and giving the idea in a sense of how it
felt inside the capitol
and how it felt outside the capitol
which is kind of shocking i mean i was
watching live that day
and i still didn't have the sense of
what was
of those two different realities that
were happening
one on the on the joint session floor in
the house and the senate floor and then
and then outside the capitol how that
was playing out
you know at the same moments of time
but it really gives you a good sense of
what actually happened in the time that
it happened in that day
and the timeline and how [ __ ]
disgusting it actually was
and every american should be forced to
watch it
maybe maybe just maybe they'll
understand what exactly is he's on trial
for here
he's not on trial for holding a rally
he's not on trial because he has
supporters that wear his hats and fly
his flags
and and and buy trump underwear
and trump bumper stickers and
can only say trump 2020 that is not what
happened that is not why he's on trial
he's on trial
because for months and months and months
and months this [ __ ]
continued to stoke these people and
convince them that january 6 there was
something that was going to happen
that somehow they could overturn an
election
and somehow it was stolen from them in
the same time
so not only not only is there two
different narratives here which is
trump's always on both sides of the
[ __ ] fence
he can never just believe something and
believe it he's gotta have both [ __ ]
ways
so the two narratives are is that the
election was stolen
and the other narrative was that we have
to take our government back we have to
take our country back
like he wasn't the incumbent or some
[ __ ] but i did a lot of tick tocks on
this
i did a lot of videos on this i did a
lot of commentary
on this at the time as this was going on
and we we remember the debate that him
and joe biden had where they brought up
the proud boys
and the proud boys kind of became the
center of this
and i did several videos on the proud
boys but i did one specifically that i
want to show you
and i'm going to walk you through a
little bit of my timeline up to january
6th
why why it makes sense to try this idiot
and convict him
and not only to convict him of inciting
an insurrection
because that's what he did the entire
time
but to also remove the possibility of
this [ __ ] ever having the reins
of government ever again
rather be the federal government or the
local [ __ ] school chapter
so let's watch this clip well merry day
after christmas let's talk
and paul poopypants is having a twitter
tantrum this morning calling on the
proud boys to come save him
i told you what this [ __ ] was up
to so wipe that cheeto ball dust off
your chin you
queueing on proud boy fake ass patriot
nazi fox
you got work to do on january 6th proud
boys why do these in-cell honey badger
[ __ ] call themselves the part
about it is the orange deity is calling
for a purge of mitch mcconnell from the
gop
it's maybe something we can agree on
here's the big [ __ ] secret
this is the way this clown show was
always gonna end
even lindsay they've got blackmail on me
graham saw it coming back in 2016.
also don't be surprised that on january
6th these probably q anon [ __ ]
will put pence in that deep state
category you know it's all part of the
cheeto chess plan
so sit back and enjoy the entertainment
because everything that trump touches
turns to liquid [ __ ]
[ __ ] him and i still stand
by my final argument there that
everything trump touches
turns to liquid [ __ ] absolute liquid
[ __ ]
so he was stoking the proud boys that
was the day after christmas that i did
that video you can tell from the very
beginning
but he'd been stoking these these these
insurrectionists
the whole month of january after
december 14th
because you know they kept telling us
after the elections like oh wait
wait wait until this happens and then
wait until this happens wait until the
supreme court
wait until december 14th and then once
december 14th did not go their way
and the state certified the vote for joe
biden and then it was january 6th
and he was on this tirade on twitter
over and over and over and over again
january 6 january 6 january 6 january 6
he kept at it and kept at it and kept
at it and kept at it and he wasn't
tweeting to the american people here
this [ __ ] the entire time he was
present wasn't tweeting to the american
people
he wasn't tweeting to people like me he
doesn't care if i'm not gonna vote for
him
it's his dog whistle he considers
twitter his dog whistle
and that's why he was so pissed off when
they took him off
it's because they took his dog whistle
away from him
and that's what he was doing the entire
month of january our entire month of
december in the beginning of january
was to stoke these people to january
sixth in particular the proud boys
now that's a whole nother goddamn
podcast on that group of
ninca poops but he was stoking them the
entire way
continuing and continuing and continuing
to stoke these morons
and then not only did you have him
stoking
stoking his these groups of people these
rank and file people out there
but you had people like rudy giuliani
cindy powell lynnwood
mike flynn mike lindell the mypelo nazi
out there on the news continuing
continuing to peddle this
[ __ ] about the kraken and dominion
voting machines and how it was stolen
and there was fake votes and dead people
voting and
martial law and insurrection act and
just just [ __ ] absolute garbage
nonsense
let me play a clip there and then and
then you'll know what i'm talking about
oh hey let's talk about some conspiracy
theory nut jobs
a whole list of these [ __ ] to
choose from really is a fun
cast of characters let's see there's
linwood
marjorie taylor green and sydney powell
grandpa farty mcsharty rudy giuliani and
mike marshall all flynn
and last but not least to join the
january sixers
is their orange deity donald trump
[ __ ] shitty [ __ ] teddy ray's sick
steady really sucks this way you'll be
crying on january 6th you'll see don't
you find it kind of funny that the
anti-participation crowd
is hedging their bet on mike [ __ ]
pence [ __ ]
almost like entering your pissy little
kid into a talent contest
thinking he can sing only to find out
that this [ __ ] can't even lip
sync to a tick-tock video worth of [ __ ]
hey january sixers we'll see you
[ __ ] on january 20th
[ __ ] them now obviously in that video i
wasn't talking about
specific people storming the capitol i
was talking about the people inciting
this
and continue to peddle this [ __ ]
about fake votes and fake voting
machines and hugo chavez and all this
just absolute [ __ ] nonsense garbage
that they're still pedaling today
i mean mike lindell the my pillow nazi
just did a three hour
documentary an infomercial
with him sitting in front of a what
looks like the 1997
daily show desk explaining to us how to
p
how a pdf file that he put together
[ __ ] proves
that donald trump's the president
jesus [ __ ] christ we're still doing
this
still
and donald trump all the while with rudy
giuliani sydney powell marjorie taylor
green
lynne wood lauren bobert mike flynn
the list goes on and on and on don jr
eric
they continue to go on the news and and
peddle this big [ __ ] lie about how it
was stolen
and really stoked these people up for
january 6th they had that date in mind
jesus christ they state even after
january 6 they continue with this
january 20th stuff and now that january
20 has happened and joe biden's
president
these dumb [ __ ] think he's in
some kind of [ __ ] set in hollywood
and then march 4th donald trump's gonna
be sworn in as his 19th president
because all of a sudden these these
[ __ ] q and on dumb [ __ ]
have become sovereign citizens and they
mixed in the [ __ ] sovereign citizen
[ __ ]
the theory into their q a on [ __ ] where
it wasn't there before
you know because if they would have
sworn in donald trump on january 20 he
wouldn't be the legitimate president
would he
what the actual hell is going on
jesus christ but they incited this they
kept inciting kept inside and kept
inciting it
and he kept tweeting about it and the
greatest news today about the democrats
and i think the best thing they did was
lay each tweet to bear in front of these
senators in the timeline that showed
that donald trump was at the crux of
this
he kept on it because let's face it
folks after december 14th when mitch
mcconnell came out on the floor of the
senate mitch mcconnell said
it's over [ __ ] not so many words that's
how i would have said it
it's over [ __ ] but when mitch mcconnell
came out and said it's over the
election's over joe biden is the
president-elect
finally after december 14th it took him
a long [ __ ] time to get there but he
finally got there
if donald trump would have went on his
twitter account and said ah
i don't concede but but
january 20th joe biden's gonna be the
president we wouldn't have had january
6th
we would not have had it without donald
trump that's for goddamn sure
and that's where the inciting comes from
because he stood up there he stood up
there and [ __ ] said it
him and rudy giuliani and alex jones the
night before and don jr i mean rudy
giuliani said
trial by combat
trial by combat is the words that he
used
and jesus christ days days before
january 6th
there was a lawsuit in texas this was
their last ditch effort of the supreme
court
you guys remember this [ __ ] they lost
their pennsylvania case
then louis gomer pulls a case against
mike pence because they have this
[ __ ]
deluded theory that somehow mike pence
was gonna [ __ ] overthrow this
election which is a dumb boneheaded
[ __ ] scheme anyways
if the vice president really has the
[ __ ] power that they said he had
why in the actual [ __ ] 2017
after hillary clinton lost a [ __ ] to
donald trump wouldn't
why would joe biden not say well i'm
just gonna make hillary the president
if they really had that power and all
the way back in 2000 when al gore lost
to george w
bush in the supreme court vice president
al gore could have just made himself
president
but he didn't because it doesn't exist
it's [ __ ] all of it
full stop it's absolute [ __ ] [ __ ]
but louis gohmert files a lawsuit in
texas
and this was their last ditch effort
before january 6. all you'll see
supreme court's gonna do this thing to
make mike pence have this power that
doesn't exist you'll see
you'll see you'll see part of the plan
part of the plan
part of the [ __ ] plan
on and on and on it went and louis
gohmert filed this lawsuit and the judge
said
[ __ ] you you can take it's a trump judge
too
trump appointed judge said you could
take this lawsuit and stick it straight
up your [ __ ] ass louie gomer where it
belongs
not in so many words i mean again if i
was the judge that's how i would have
said it
you know i have a little more colorful
language than a federal judge
that's why i'm not a [ __ ] federal
judge i just [ __ ] about them
let me play you a clip on louis gohmert
and i'll talk to you on the other side
of it well welcome to 2021 [ __ ]
let's talk it's a lot of stories to get
to but let's start with this horse's
dick down in texas
louie gohmert why does he sound like a
character from the beverly hillbillies
the trump appointed federal judge down
in texas tells louis gomer to take his
lawsuit and stick it straight up his ass
even mike pence didn't want to be in the
same room as this [ __ ] lawsuit
he must have thought that the lawsuits
preferred gender was a woman
and he didn't want to piss off mother
things are pretty bad when donald trump
lost his number one fluffer
things aren't looking up for january 6.
this has really got louie's butthole in
a pinch
but what does old louie do he puts on
his trump knee pads goes on newsmax
and calls for violence in the streets
wondering what they're going to call it
when white fascist proud boys burn down
a bunch of targets they won't call it
looting and rioting because republican
white people don't do that type of stuff
something clever like peaceful proud boy
privilege protest
[ __ ] him peaceful proud boy privileged
protest i wasn't too [ __ ] far off and
then when that narrative didn't work
when that narrative didn't work and they
realized they couldn't hide the fact
that this insurrection was violent and
deadly
and it was designed to overthrow the
government the united states and the
constitution the united states of
america
they backed away from that and said oh
it's black lives matter and antifa
didn't you see them they stole their
they stole their clothes and put their
clothes on and marched out of the cabin
act like damn what the [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] up
those are [ __ ] trump supporters
never seen antifa supporters have that
less of teeth antifa supporters
generally have a full
full grill they got teeth
and it looks like they own a treadmill
or something right
it doesn't look like their [ __ ] diets
consist of pizza and ding dongs
i'm not talking about i'm talking about
cupcake ding dongs hostess ding dongs
jeez don't get your undies in a [ __ ]
bundle
but louis gohmert gets on on [ __ ]
newsmax
and says it out loud says the quiet part
out loud
i guess the only way that we will be
able to overturn this election
is if there's violence and by violence
only
says it out loud and louis gomer
on the day of the insurrection after it
happened
he still voted still voted to contest it
because he was probably cheering in his
p little brain
while it was happening because he
incited it
trump incited it holly incited it cruz
and cited it
giuliani marjorie taylor green bobert
they all incited it
1776. stop the steal
it was all to incite a band of ninka
poops
to go to the capitol and try to stop the
certification of the election
which was not going to happen because
really honestly even if they would have
stopped the certification it wouldn't
change the results in the first place
it's a [ __ ] ceremonial thing anyways
the state's already certified it that
it's done
at that point the thing they were trying
to stop was the [ __ ] ceremony
it was like them storming the oscars to
try to prevent
them from reading the results of the
[ __ ] envelope
it had already been voted on it already
been decided
all that [ __ ] ceremony was to hand
out the goddamn oscar
and to make sure that the country knew
that joe biden was our
president-elect ceremonial
that's it you dumb [ __ ]
and you killed five [ __ ] people five
people died
because you had this deluded [ __ ]
belief that somehow mike pence
could overthrow the ceremony or some
[ __ ] some dumb [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] they believe
but then we we fast forward to january
6th
because the two supreme court cases
didn't work pennsylvania or texas
december 4th 14th didn't go their way
so we fast forward to january 6 and they
decide they're going to have a rally
because they know they're going to have
a crowd
and they know the crowd is going to be
easily incited into a riot
and they know the riot will be easily
incited into an insurrection
why the [ __ ] would they have gallows
prepared for mike pence
and if anyone doesn't believe that that
gallow was not prepared for mike pence
you just watched the video these fat
ignorant [ __ ] hillbilly [ __ ]
standing outside with their white
privilege and their white supremacy
yelling hang my pits hang mike pence
they [ __ ] said it they were chanting
it
we fast forward to january 6 to the
rally
now i don't normally include myself into
these stories
but i was about to do my tick tock that
day i was going to go out and do my walk
and right before i did my walk donald
trump came on tv
and i decided to watch his speech
right before i did my tick tock and i
did my first one
on that speech
here's what i said now this is before
the insurrection
right before it i posted this video
after it
because i was so [ __ ] dumbfounded
that these people actually
were gonna break into the capital and
try to try to stop
this process a process that was only
ceremonial in the first place
i was so [ __ ] dumbfounded by that i
had to post it after the fact
but i recorded it before so let me show
it to you and i talk about it on the
other side
wackadoos are out in full force today
let's talk so the nutmeg and chief is
rallying up his crowd really is getting
the january sixers pumped up to [ __ ]
lose
he does want everyone to know that it's
gonna be mike pence's fault that he
loses
not his just like everything else this
piece of [ __ ] does in life
he's not the one to blame it's someone
else stop blaming me
he's lost the house buried the senate
with his phone call to georgia and his
[ __ ] supporters are finally gonna
realize
he lost the presidency too it's a little
[ __ ] piece of advice
to all you mangaku and on january sixers
out there
drop on your [ __ ] seat belts because
last night in georgia was just a prelude
of the reality that is about to rain
down on you dumb [ __ ]
it's not matter if trump concedes or not
and oh by the way that [ __ ]
delusional loophole power that you think
pence has it doesn't exist good luck
[ __ ]
[ __ ] them
so that was my immediate reaction right
after his speech to his
to his supporters at the rally in
washington dc on january 6 before they
stormed down to the capitol
and got five people [ __ ] killed and
tried to kill more
because this just wasn't a [ __ ]
innocent march down to the
down to the capital and it turned into
something bigger
they're still looking for the pipe bomb
guy
they had pipe bombs and semi-automatic
rifles
and a gallows two of the guys that were
arrested
in this that were in the senate chamber
had zip tie cuffs they planned on taking
hostages
something they planned on detaining
somebody
so who was it was it the was it mike
pence the guy that they were
outside chanting hang mike pence
you think that had something to do with
it you think they planted [ __ ] pipe
bombs at the rnc in the dnc because
they didn't see the dnc as the only
enemy here
they seen the rnc they were trying to
overthrow the entire [ __ ] government
people
and the person at the head of this was
donald trump
he's a president united states he's the
leader of their
i mean jesus christ they weren't flying
mike pence 2020 flags
in the back of their cars they weren't
flying trump pence flags on the back of
their trucks
it was trump trump 2020. they never said
pinch 20 20.
they always said trump 2020.
because he's their [ __ ] mango jesus
he's their orange deity
and they were there for him and anything
he said they would
do even jenna ryan on two national on
two interviews
said i don't feel guilty and the reason
why i don't feel guilty is because the
president told us to do it
and we were just doing what the
president wanted us to do
even the [ __ ] q anon shaman this
[ __ ] [ __ ] the guy with the horns
same defense oh i i
feel i feel like donald trump duped me
i feel like he do well that's your
[ __ ] radar picking up facts dummy
he did dupe you you dumb [ __ ]
and that's the whole point here this
trial
and the democrats are laying out a
goddamn good case
and it's really easy to lay out a good
case here it ain't like donald trump did
this [ __ ] in the back room and i'm sure
there's a
plenty of private phone calls to certain
groups and certain people
that would lock this case up even more
and i'm sure we'll see that in a federal
criminal court soon
soon we'll see that that evidence in a
federal court
but this trial for for inciting an
insurrection
the impeachment of him while he was
president
they impeached him while he was
president and if you're so worried about
the [ __ ] constitutionality of this
why the [ __ ] didn't mitch mcconnell go
ahead and start the trial when
donald trump was still president jesus
christ you ram a [ __ ]
supreme court justice down our throat in
four hours
you could surely have a goddamn senate
trial
of donald j trump inciting an
insurrection
get spare me the [ __ ] about the
constitutionality about it
you can take the [ __ ]
constitutionality of this trial and
stick it straight up your ass
so we will hear
the rest of today and tomorrow the
argument that the
democratic house managers will lay out
the case against donald trump was really
easy because he tweeted and he talked
into a microphone and he said these
things
it's not hard to get this evidence and
these [ __ ] boneheaded
maga idiots these insurrectionists these
seditious insurrectionists that went in
and and tried to overthrow the
government the united states
live stream the [ __ ] they're recording
themselves doing it and proud of it
jesus christ you've seen you've seen
several in the in the
the bulletproof brawls as i call them
with their cell phone right in the front
right in the front of their chest to
record everything
all the while being tracked now that we
know oh who would have thought if they
were carrying around their cell phone
they would have been tracked
their location would have been tracked
because that's what a cell phone does
you dumb [ __ ]
it tracks you it's what it does
and we see the footage we see the tweets
we see the public
statements of these morons donald trump
in particular
and the best part about the case that
the democrats are making
the best part is they keep calling him
president trump
as if it's the present and again i don't
like to hear that i'd rather hear you
know former
president trump or our ex-president
trump
but they're making the case that he was
the president while he did this
he was the president and that is the
indictment
here that is the impeachment is on the
office of
the president donald trump to be
specific
and that he incited an insurrection
while he was
president and spare me the
constitutionality of it because your
argument's so [ __ ] thin
then i'm beginning to think that the
reason why you have the constitutional
constitutionality argument is because
you have no argument because there's so
much [ __ ] evidence that he incited
this thing that you think he's gonna
lose
and maybe mitch mcconnell is maybe he is
whipping secret boats
to get rid of this [ __ ]
and to convict him which would bury his
hopes for 2024
and bury his hopes of being the party
leader which liz cheney
mitt romney pat toomey mitch mcconnell
john thune ben sasse
nothing would please them more then for
for these trump morons to go splinter
off and try to start their own party
because let me tell you something that i
said in the video just before
everything donald trump touches turns to
liquid [ __ ]
every [ __ ] bit of it republican party
or if he started his own party
all of it he [ __ ] up casinos he [ __ ]
up real estate
he [ __ ] up the apprentice he [ __ ] up
truck stakes he [ __ ] up his golf
courses
he's a [ __ ] loser he [ __ ] lost the
first election
the popular vote he lost the second
election by even more of a popular vote
he lost every single one of his [ __ ]
court cases but one insignificant one
almost 60 [ __ ] court cases they lost
they lost two supreme court cases
they lost they lost this [ __ ] theory
that they were going to have legislators
overturn this thing
and then they lost on january 6th
and he will continue to lose because
that's what he [ __ ] is
he's a [ __ ] loser
so come to grips with it trumpers
he's he's he's gonna lose this one too
rather he gets voted to convict or not
history is going to convict donald trump
and more importantly
history is going to judge and convict
the
the [ __ ] complicit
fascist of republicans that are senators
that are going to vote not to convict
history will judge them folks
that is the best part about this whole
thing is this trial is beginning to not
be a trial about donald trump
because the evidence that the democratic
managers are presenting
although although it's easy to to get
this evidence
it is a compelling way in the order in
which they are presenting it
and it's not making much of a case not
to convict donald trump but now it's
going to be about the legacy vote of
these republicans
and that is the conviction that will
ultimately happen here
needs to happen his public opinion and
history
will judge these republicans by how they
will vote
and i believe that's why they got six
votes the other day for the
constitutionality of this
as those six senators know what the
judgment's gonna be on their legacy
they know long term that that people are
going to remember
what is going to happen on this vote and
they won't remember the
constitutionality vote
no one's going to remember the vote that
happened yesterday none of them
not a person will probably ever bring it
up ever unless you watch some long-term
long long-ended documentary
the vote that's going to matter is to
convict or not to convict that's the
legacy vote here
and there's only been one one
senator that has ever in the history of
our country voted against his party
in an impeachment trial and that was
mitt romney
just one so think of the significance of
eight to ten votes
think of the significance of history
not in the moment not to get conviction
because i i believe
that donald trump and his family and his
allies their legal troubles after this
trial is not over it's only beginning
this is only the beginning of the next
two years
of donald trump and his allies going to
court and anyone thinks anyone that he
pardoned
is going to stop crime and stuff stop
being criminals all of a sudden
just because he pardoned them
well i got some [ __ ] jewish space
lasers and a pizza parlor in the
basement
in washington dc that i'd like to
[ __ ] sell you
so let's sit back and enjoy the show
because that's what this is going to be
as a show the democratic managers have
put on the evidence they're going to lay
out the evidence in a way that's
professional
honest and truthful about the big lie
that these [ __ ] incited and
then incited into violence and donald
trump was at the crux of it
and then the entertaining part
what will come after that trump's
defense
which we've already seen there's not
much of one
so he won't have much of one
it'll be very interesting to see
i appreciate you guys joining me today
on the podcast number five we are at
episode number five already this is
[ __ ] fantastic and i appreciate all
your guys's support
um it is it is i have had so much fun
doing this podcast so far
and i i hope you guys keep tuning in i
hope you keep listening to my absolute
uh rage on rants uh about this stuff
that's happening in our country
and i want to invite you to subscribe to
the youtube channel now follow me on
twitter and if you're not on tic tac i
don't even know how you found me really
uh come come join me on tick tock two
for my my videos on tick tock
uh we really do appreciate it and catch
catch the other videos that i do here on
youtube
uh we do uh a video series it's called
the side piece we're not trying to cheat
on the podcast
it's just our side piece we got all pass
for the side piece
so i do some some short rants and they
live just here on youtube they won't be
on the podcast so if you are listening
out there on spotify or press sprout or
apple
and then you're just listening to the
audio of this you have to come to the
youtube channel
and you have to listen to the side piece
it's very important
those are those are great great great
rants we i take one topic
and i ran for about five or ten minutes
on that one topic and i do them about
five or six days a week
so come check those out if you haven't
already and i've been posting my tick
tocks on youtube here too
so check those out if you're if you're
listening out there on the podcast come
over to youtube and
check those out follow me on twitter and
again follow me on tick tock if you're
not following me on tick tock geez
i don't understand how you even found me
but go to thetonymichaels.com all the
links are there to follow me
uh check out the merch store we got uh
coffee cups we got [ __ ] em stickers
we're gonna have [ __ ]
hacks here soon i promise i promise
we're gonna have ads just like this just
like i wear in the videos
and they're gonna say [ __ ] em on it my
[ __ ] logo
they'll be on there so so stay tuned for
that
uh and any of the money that you spend
in the merch store uh you
you will it will go towards the podcast
here for future episodes
future equipment to make the show better
and i appreciate all the support i
really do people have already started to
buy coffee cups and stickers and shirts
and hoodies
i even have pairs of sweatpants you can
buy [ __ ] sweatpants
where on earth can you buy [ __ ] um
sweatpants other than the
tonymichaels.com merch store
so go to thetonymichaels.com if you go
to the merch store
uh use the promo code podcast
use the promo code podcast and you'll
get 10 off your entire order
go to the merch store and use the promo
code
code podcast and you will get 10
off your order so check that out for us
and i really appreciate that
guys we are going to have a fun-filled
week ahead of us here
with this trial um and i'm sure next
week when we come back on we will be
talking a lot about this trial i do have
a guest scheduled for next week
um we really want to talk about the
psychology of q anon
i i've been wanting to talk about this
topic for a while and how
how people have actually believed in
this this q anon conspiracy theories how
it relates to white supremacy groups
how it also is tied to christianity in
this country uh the evangelical
christians
and how that all ties together and how
people are roped into this belief
uh of absolute madness and then things
that
that don't even logically make sense so
we're going to talk about that next week
with our guest
so stay tuned next week for that again
wednesday's three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern live on
youtube and we'll post up the audio on
the podcast
directories after that so you guys can
listen to it so stay
tuned and i really do appreciate you
thank you thank you thank you
for joining us today and watching this
video and
uh you know if you don't like it you
know
i guess keep watching it but [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me [ __ ]
them